und am tatort steht jetzt mein kollege
jan frederik langs hausen werden jetzt
haben wir gerade schon gehört es gab
einen verletzten wie sieht die situation
jetzt geradeaus ist die polizei noch
immer vor ort
ja die ist aktuell vor ort man sieht sie
auch noch bei mir hier im hintergrund
ich muss an dieser stelle einmal
korrigieren ist weil kein überfall auf
einen geldtransporter sondern den neuen
erkenntnissen nach war es jetzt den ball
direkt auf die bankfiliale die volksbank
die man hier dann hier auch bei mir im
hintergrund sieht die täter sind quasi
auf die einfahrt wie man da auch bei den
volksbank filialen schild sieht
raufgefahren anschließend haben sie
versucht in das gebäude einzudringen
es gab einen schusswechsel weil auch
sicherheitspersonal da war und dann
haben sie ja auch schon mit dem sie da
rein gefahren sind in brand gesteckt und
sind sollte es uns ein augenzeuge
erzählt über eine böschung geflüchtet
und hier im hintergrund von der
volksbank verläuft eine autobahn und
diese die täter sollen diese autobahn
hochgeklettert seien wo bereits dann ein
fluchtwagen stand und mit denen sollen
sie dann entkommen so konnten sie denn
beute erzählen bei diesem überfall
das ist aktuell noch nicht klar
man hatte ja mein spieler anfangs schon
gesehen dass es im 13 juli einen
banküberfall genau auf dieselbe filiale
gegeben hat auch hier ist noch nicht
klar ob beute gemacht wurde das ist
alles derzeit noch stand oder ein
unklarer stand der ermittlungen wie die
polizei mitgeteilt hat